welcome back to New rockstars I'm Tommy
bechtold and this week we got the
trailer for the new Nicholas Cage
vampire horror comedy Renfield now
Nicholas Cage is obviously playing the
iconic Count Dracula in this film but us
true cajaholics know this isn't the
first time that Nick has sunk his teeth
into the role of vampire no that would
be the 1988 horror comedy Vampire's Kiss
in which cage plays a publishing
executive who believes he has been
bitten by a woman and is turning into a
vampire
[Music]
yes you are Nicholas needless to say
Renfield will be a real promotion for
Nicholas Cage as he goes from Vampire
Lackey to Big Bad draki the trailer
itself bounces back and forth between
cages familiar played by Nicholas hope
and scenes of just gruesome vampire Gore
I gotta say humor vampire violence Count
Me In guys what do you think should we
break down the whole trailer do you want
to see a whole Renfield movie breakdown
let me know in the comments let's get it
out there I know I do